This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6MtEnglish
from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Rob.
And I'm Georgina.
Now Georgina, how resilient are you?
Resilient? You mean able to cope with difficult situations?
I have a pile of work to do today, but I'm remaining calm and not getting stressed.
Well that's good. You are showing resilience.
And today we're discussing whether we're born with resilience or we have to learn it.
Okay Rob. But first I expect you're going to ask me a question.
Bring it on.
Okay. Resilience is also a word used in science to describe the characteristic of a substance or object.
But what does it mean?
A that it's very tough or hard, B that it can return to its original shape after being bent,
or C it can turn from a solid into a liquid quickly.
I have a feeling it means B, an object that returns to its original shape after being bent.
Okay. I'll let you know if you were correct at the end of the programme.
But let's talk more about human resilience.
There are many self-help books and motivational speakers all promising us we can learn to be resilient.
Well it is a useful trait to have and it's something that can help you deal with many difficult
situations from coping with the pressures of work to handling the death of a loved one.
And it's more than just telling someone to toughen up or get a grip as Dr David Wesley knows.
He is head of psychology at Middlesex University and talked about levels of resilience on the BBC World
Service programme, the Y Factor.
First of all there's our social supports, our communities, our families, the people are important
to us, the organisations we work for. So one way we can look at resilience is to measure that.
The amount of social support available to us.
Another way to think about resilience is to think about how we think about the situations we're in.
So for example, one way to look at that would be just to look at how optimistic people are
as a guide to how resilient they might be when times get tough.
And then a third level that we can look at for resilience is a biological level.
How well we can sue ourselves, calm ourselves down, how well we can actually regulate our
own nervous systems at times of distress.
Right so Dr Wesley describes social supports. The people around us who we can talk to and support
us and generally make us feel better. I think he's saying with more support we'll feel more
resilient. It's interesting to note that a resilient person isn't necessarily someone quiet
who doesn't make a fuss and gets on with things. Some experts think it's people who ask for help
and use this social support network who are acting in a more resilient way.
It's a good point and another level of resilience is how optimistic someone is.
Being optimistic means having positive thoughts about the future and believing things will
turn out well. A positive mind means you can deal with situations that at first look tough.
Another level Dr Wesley mentioned was our biological level. How are bodies cope in times of distress.
Distress is the feeling you get when you are worried or upset by something.
So when we're distressed a resilient person is able to soothe his or her body and regulate his or
her nervous system which helps them stay calm. But Rob the big question is are we born with resilience
or can we learn it? Experts speaking on the Y Factor program tended to think it could be learned.
Yes one of them is Anne Maston a professor at the University of Minnesota. From her studies she
found it was something that we learn when we need to. Anne Maston talks about how some of the
children she studied manifest resilience from the start. When something manifests it shows clearly
and is easy to notice. They remain resilient despite adversity at difficult time in their life
that they have had to face. Other children what she calls the late bloomers started off less resilient,
struggled with adversity but turned their lives around by becoming more resilient. Maybe we can learn
resilience from having a bad experience. Well one thing Anne went on to say was that families
and friends can be a great support and help with resilience. Those that were late bloomers only
connected with adults and mentors later in life. Yes she says that teachers or parents are role models
in how to handle adversity and children are watching they're learning from the adults around them
by seeing how they react when they get challenged by something. Time now to find out how resilient you
are when you discover the correct answer to the question I asked earlier. I said that resilience
is also a word used in science to describe the characteristic of a substance or object but what does
that mean? Is it A it's very tough or hard B it can return to its original shape after being bent
or C it can turn from a solid into a liquid quickly and what did you say Georgina? I said it was B
can return to its original shape after being bent. And you are right well done. Bamboo is a good
example of a resilient material you can bend it it doesn't break and returns to its original shape.
Thanks to the Science lesson Rob now we need to recap the vocabulary we've mentioned today.
Yes we've talked about being resilient an adjective that describes someone's ability to cope
with difficult situations. When you do this you show resilience. Someone who is optimistic has
positive thoughts about the future and believes things will turn out well. Distress is the feeling
you get when you are worried or upset by something. When something manifests itself it shows clearly
and is easy to notice and adversity is a difficult time in somebody's life that they've had to face.
And that brings us to the end of this discussion about resilience. Please join us again next time.
Bye bye.